yeah welcome to this video a new blitz
game playing alive yeah better than that
I guess alright we get an Italian game
but d3 the JUCO pianissimo notices the
JUCO pianist evil or just the juco piano
yeah wallet sir it is a quiet opening no
doubt about that strange p ignores the
night a five idea on Queenie forces
queen air force is the idea Queen f1
check c6 beef or something like that but
it looks looks like nonsense that keep
spending time on those kind of silly
ideas when you can instead play stuff
like that which is really equalizing
without any em any big effort okay can i
play d5 here is this bad that's some
activate pieces I don't think it okay he
allows me to try it let's do that
how to continue it will be 998 to the
successes of rather useful maneuver I
have seen there before
go in here may be controlling f5
preparing rook d8 group the a drop this
subgroup d8 something like that up
fairly I'd say fairly equal this
position
hard from both sides to to make some
substantial progress yeah Queen six is a
very cheap trick intending to take on g3
but sometimes those cheap tricks are
working this one you can play Knight h5
and i trapped myself Queen B five you
will play it should be too it's not
really bringing any benefits
I to g6 not sure there's really not
happening much here but I don't really
give its not not such a bad move anyway
and you never know maybe he's
overlooking this the bishop on a 7
sometimes says it's this kind of sniper
roll it so far away from the action but
it is doing something right h5 good
Queen g fire and I can take a fall sorry
so i can take g3 this was the idea all
along a night h4s not really doing
anything against that yeah what now
I can do that it's not it's not bad
tickling him really don't have fun a
constructive plan here don't want to
move this annoyed because of night f5
yeah I know kind of a nothing moved but
I have nowhere no big idea well Queen g6
maybe this wasn't so grateful what wow
oh my queen if I'm the queen maneuvers
this looks really really bad we got age
7 ah what the heck did i do here Oh My
Jesus ah
well
can just rip g3 probably 96 but wow what
an ugly position
he's threatening to take it what'd you
70 mean
huh yeah that's just resigned this well
the computer actually believe sir I'm
halfway okay here with this stuff yeah
maybe I should have yeah just for
because I don't have anything else but
what we have it still looks in a crap
it's 0.6 you have an applet is like a
completed yet what the heck was I doing
there with the Queen I didn't really
have a plan I mean this is obvious from
the game resorting to this simple trick
and then I asked what what the heck is
am i doing yeah playing with our plan is
always always bad I mean it's clear that
black shouldn't be in any any trouble
here but what exactly is is my idea hmm
hard to tell this one but what's the
improvement i mean i have a pro have
problems with so pieces knight on c6 the
size is always a bit of a problem in
this opening maybe I should have tried
to improve this night it's always
looking at those squares and it doesn't
do much yeah okay I mean this is
probably it's nonsense but it doesn't
spoil much and here i simply completely
overlooked night eh for even this yes is
nothing special for white what should
white have here but I overnight each
foil oh this is this is looking really
sick now yeah this is strong work T 3
yeah this is the computer points this
out as a mistake but it said won the
game I'd I'm under such pressure so the
best move according to the computer is
going to f1 yeah computer with the ideas
that night f5 is very strong and this
prevents any counter play I have I can
play anything and then this is much
stronger even because now I don't have
this yeah winning the the Queen's Own
I'm totally busted but okay Queen f1 is
not a blitz blitz game move on between
humans a TI didn't see anything against
this yeah maybe this is playable but ok
it's a very deserved loss i played this
like an idiot playing all this Queen
moves really bad but I didn't really
have a good plan here what's the plan
he's analyzing a bit and putting some
some move from the board yeah all this
isn't too clear but ok it's it's I
couldn't I couldn't couldn't defend yeah
yeah well thanks for watching this I
mean have pretty pretty tough loss